oh that looks rad
they probably had the discussion
something like it doesn't look as real
and somebody else goes i know but it's
for children and they want a big red
puppy
oh that's so cool dude people's minds
must have been blown
the tech they use in this is also the
tech they use for the matrix bullet time
big thanks to root insurance for
sponsoring today's episode stick around
to the end to see how you could save up
to 900
on your car insurance hey what's up
welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artist react today we've
got a very cool guest
he's right where he's
what's up guys welcome back how's it
going
with the can yeah yeah it was from way
up there you guys got to get that whole
patch
yeah what are you doing on a roof ah
just you know just
seeing what's up well we happened to
have
a spot and we needed to fill for vfx
artists react thank you for joining us
once again absolutely it's good to be
back it's been a lot of
freaking times good to see you guys yeah
probably not reacting to a lot of new
vfx shots
from classic films that we know and love
i figured maybe we could do a little bit
more of that did you guys ever read the
book
clifford the big red dog as a kid no you
didn't read the book but i occasionally
caught the pbs cartoon oh it's a cartoon
well now it's a movie and it's coming
out this fall
you may not believe it but there is
magic all around us so it starts off
with a little small doggy and he's cute
oh it's a very red dog oh watch this
ready for it
[Music]
that's all it took the tear of norfolk
clifford so what are your gut reactions
when you see this this
dog it's actually really pretty good the
cg looks really solid but it's just very
clearly like
an animated cg character in the scene
yeah i think the problem is the fact
that it's so uncanny
just by the nature of it being an off
color like that it's going to tickle our
brains in a weird way of like
something's off
i feel like they're doing a touch of
post-processing he's already read but i
feel like they're kind of committing to
having him be 100
tinted red because like his shadowy
areas should become less saturated some
of the shadow areas
should not be red same with some of the
highlight areas they wouldn't be red i
think there's basically going all right
everything that's within the bounds of
this dog's outline
is going to be red it's not clifford the
big kind of red dog it's clifford the
big red
dog it is very red they probably had the
discussion something like
it doesn't look as real and somebody
else goes i know but it's for children
and they want a big red puppy the
overall red
is slightly on the desaturated side i
think they went the same route as like
doing the hulk in the avengers movies
where it's like
slightly less green the physics of the
dog's ears are
very well done the floppy ears and like
the way they actually kind of like hold
the structure it's really well done i
think at this point cgi
has got it down where they can do a big
red dog and have it look great
it's probably just having it blend with
the people around it and interacting
with the environment
okay well that's what they actually
didn't look like right there that's
pretty rough shadows it's just the
painted shadows
but look at the the zorb the zorb is
probably added into actually look at the
trees in the background
the trees in the background are
establishing what color your shadow
should be and the color under clifford
is not that at all
now notice how like under his feet the
shadow's not getting darker as his foot
gets closer to the ground
there's like a little bit of it but it's
kind of just one flat
dark color and also notice how the
feathering of that shadow doesn't change
correctly with the perspective of the
ground
it's uniform it's a uniform feather this
is an example of good shadows
nice general soft shadow but also see
how there's a really dynamic dark
shadows right under his feet where he's
making contact and it follows the
geometry of the ground correctly
it's matching the shadows into the zorb
and smashing the shadows in the
background
this is probably a really early shot
they probably don't have a shadow pass
and somebody went in
and just like did it by hand really
quick for the trailer they're not going
to finish
a shot to 100 completion when it's still
up in the air like what the animation is
going to be or does it work with the
scene are you getting the proper
character
and you know they probably wanted this
sequence for the trailer and so you're
using something that's like ah this is
close enough yeah it's always important
to note that you can't
harshly criticize the effects in a
trailer because they're not finished
i think at the end of the day though the
filmmakers are just kind of embraced
this is a cartoon character
yeah it's not supposed to look real and
because of that like this piece is going
to be entirely dependent on the writing
and the characters and the story
it's not really dependent on how good
the visual effects are they just need to
be good enough
the moral of this story i think is that
people expected us to roast
this but it's not bad it's not bad it's
a big red dog it looks great
it's not bad in what we would roast it's
trailer footage so i don't want to be
like mean to people for
putting their half-finished work in a
trailer like yeah
it happens all the time it's not sonic
and they did fix sonic
enough kitty friendly stuff let's go to
a horror film from 1933. welcome to the
invisible man from 1933 this is a film
that was recommended in the
comments earlier when i was asking about
old vfx it doesn't look very invisible
to me
well he's wearing clothes right yeah
clothes are not invisible
all right i'll show you there's a soup
oh my god that'd be terrifying
how are we seeing through to the back
side there
[Laughter]
oh that's so cool oh my god dude
people's minds
must have been blown dude i love how he
chucks his bandages at them
what is this stuff invisible stuff
the thing that blows me away is the very
beginning of the shot when we can see
through his nose and eye sockets
it's a puppet thing yeah and there's
like hands coming up and
interacting with them okay and you can
tell because like his head doesn't
rotate at all it just locks
looking straight ahead and his arms are
moving but it's like
yeah that's the only reason i could tell
yeah people's bodies don't move that way
and also the weight is too light
but then we got to another shot from
behind and he takes off his hair and
suddenly
there's no head there oh it's
transparent the bandage is transparent
what does that mean
he's wearing a bald cap that's tied down
really tight or something
it's basically just another
old-fashioned green screen trick and
it's extra apparent because they can't
paint back in the other side of his
bandage so he takes the bandage off now
we should be able to see the other side
of the bandage
you know and like right here as he pulls
the bandage off you can see where his
head is obscuring
the bandage right there there's an
invisible gap where the advantage is now
behind his head and it's blocking it and
then it reveals as it comes around the
shape of his head there so here's how he
did it first they record the background
with you know the actors reacting to
nothing but it's all timed up very
specifically and they used the exact
same set and they draped
black i think vellum over everything or
basically velvet all those little tufts
of black
capture light better because it's not a
flat surface where light can bounce off
it's a bunch of like fingers
it's light coming and bounces through
all those little fingers and then the
actor himself is actually wearing a
black velvet head mold and then the
elements on top that aren't black
he's still wearing a black suit but it's
not like black velvet it's still picking
up some light
him being invisible is him just being
completely void of light
right then what they do is they take
that film shot of him and they make it
super super high contrast
and you end up basically with a cut out
but it's not a perfect cutout because
you know there's still parts where the
shadow and things like that so then
somebody goes into the paintbrush and
they fill in all those little holes
on that piece of film they end up with
four pieces they have the background
plate
the high contrast plate the inverse the
high contrast plate and they finally
have
the actor himself which is filmed
without the high contrast yeah
and then you get your final exposure
dude that would take days
now in after effects that's like two
clicks they're having to
match two different cutouts like a
puzzle piece where today we have layers
and so we just we don't even need to do
the second part of that
that's why it blows me away that we
don't see the track matte lines more
frequently because it's like
you have to line it up literally photon
perfect in order to not have like a tiny
black line
you see that a lot in older movies
anytime they're doing some sort of
effect like this
but this is still nonetheless a really
cool visual magic trick it's so cool
so ryan here has just had surgery on his
shoulder so for everyone
you knew it wasn't that one so okay for
every subscription
that we get to this video ren gets one
more
cell added to his bones when they heal
let's get rend back to 100 health and
get him at least a million new germs
sorry
sales a million new cells he's germany
enough the point i'm trying to make is
i'd just really appreciate it if you'd
subscribe
if you enjoy this channel thank you
chevron one is holding
have either you guys seen stargate no so
i've not actually seen stargate this
movie was recommended
online because the portal is actually
pretty sweet and there's a really fun
story behind it
oh yeah give me those graphs ancient ui
designs all right you ready for it you
ready for it
not the symbol sequence complete
oh that looks rad looks great
so that portal effect was pretty sweet
yeah it was rad
and the guy who came up with it got
fired twice
before doing it so roland emmerich
directed this and he
hated visual effects he thought
everything had to be done practically
with miniatures
in camera and so when they were trying
to r d how
this portal should look he was hating
everything rejecting
everything they tried jeffrey oaken the
visual effects supervisor
on this movie ended up kind of
accidentally discovering something
really cool
he had figured out basically a way where
you can look at the underside of water
and it has like a cool rippling effect
to it and so he was setting up this
tank of water and filming it from down
below they poured in a bunch of like
iced tea
and the mixing up of it actually created
this really cool vortex
and like oh i think we're kind of onto
something here and roland nimrick was
like that's the worst thing i've ever
seen in my life
you're off you're fired you're fired
what they had the rest of the day and
they're like well i guess let's just
keep playing around so then they took an
air compressor
and it made that little initial blast
the initial block that initial blast of
the portal opening
is literally just a bunch of air being
thrown down into a tank
that's so cool and then he went back to
roland emerick and showed him that
caplus shot and he's like
you're not fired this shot's excellent
so are they
keying out the like solid color of the
water around that
water blast well he also came up with
what's called the periwinkle effect
which is a way to blue screen stuff
underwater oh really
and then for the actual ripple of the
portal in a stable
opening that is cg okay that's the only
part that i was like
and then from there it's just simply a
matter of compositing into the shot and
it works really well so good it feels
very special very unique
so he got rehired because he's like this
is sick yes but then how did he get
fired again there's another shot later
on where the dude actually goes through
the portal and then he's like
transferring over to the other galaxy or
wherever it goes
and roland emerick hated it and fired
him on the spot and then i guess rehired
him before the end of the show i don't
know roland emerick kind of seems a
little uh
intense and temperamental yeah this
ended up becoming a staple of
every single episode of stargate there
are seasons upon seasons of this and
this exact same effect was used every
single time the portal opens
i love using natural phenomenon to like
get cool effects
yeah that one was recommended in the
youtube comments if you've got any other
cool shots
leave a comment down below
[Applause]
so speaking of recommendations in the
comments here's another wonderful one
what dreams may come starring robin
williams in the greatest year for cinema
ever in 1999.
[Music]
the plants are like oil painted yeah we
say
things look painterly but this literally
looks painterly
wait what i love how he's like kind of
grossed out by it but it's also very
pleasant
at the same time so you might be
surprised to find the tech they use in
this
is also the tech they use for the matrix
bullet time huh
wait you're talking about like the
multi-camera spinning thing yeah
wait what that makes no sense there's
something called
optical flow and this is one of the
first implementations of it what optical
flow does
is it looks at the frames in your video
it tries to track pixels and how they
move through the scene so with every
pixel you have a vector
saying that it's moving in this
direction you can then put stuff on top
of it and have that stuff
flow and move with the directions of the
pixels what they did here is they have
they filmed all this footage
on real sets with a bunch of like extra
colorful flowers and stuff that they
added in
they 3d tracked their scene and they put
particles all over the scene and those
particles were little bits of paint
swatches
oh and they pinned all those particles
to points in the scene and then what
they did is they used optical flow to
then
flow those particles through the shot as
things like move and brush in the wind
and whatnot
it's really really ingenious it looks
super cool
so how does this all relate to the
matrix well the same visual effects
company was trying to figure out how to
do the bullet time thing like okay what
if we did a bunch of cameras in a circle
we're like well
it doesn't give us enough frames for
smooth motion so instead let's just take
all those frames
run an optical flow path so we can kind
of try to figure out where those pixels
have moved and then we can just do
smears
in between those frames to create the
interpolated frames
almost like a morph you know like
exactly i feel like my most common use
for this
is to make choppy slow-mo look like
smooth slow-mo
yep that's the most common one in fact
the first plug-in to ever allow us to do
that was a plugin called twixter
and twixter was made by the people that
made this effect
oh really interesting really they won an
oscar for best visual effects actually
in the same year that the matrix came
out the matrix probably should have won
it let's be honest wait
okay yeah you're probably right we're
talking about 1999 being
the best year of cinema and this is the
movie that won the oscar for best visual
effects
yep i'm gonna be honest it looks all
right it's like
really they put all this work into that
for that
okay meanwhile the matrix is still
everyone's favorite movie
20 years later fight club oh fight club
ass ride which also came out in 99.
yo clint so you recently did a really
cool community render challenge i got to
be a judge for it yeah
tell me a little bit about that and
what's coming next so i challenged
the 3d community to create the coolest
render
from a prompt that i provided the
results were insane
and probably by the time this episode
comes out i'll be knee-deep
in the third community challenge where
i'm challenging you guys so basically
take a ball from point a
and build your own contraption and get
it out the exit from point b
and i'll stack them all together and
it's gonna make the biggest rube
goldberg contraption
and we actually made our own submission
we made a whole zombie murdering machine
and the video about that comes out
tomorrow stay tuned
come along with me i'm gonna be walking
you guys through my process
every saturday i'm doing live streams
yeah if you're watching this episode
basically right when it drops
chances are clint is streaming right now
come on back and learn some vfx with me
it'll be a good time
you might notice this set is from the
regular react show but today it's been
taken over
by the son of a dungeon production but
that's not why i'm here i'm here to talk
to you
about this man over here oh hey what's
going on jake hey matt how did last week
go
oh not so great i gotta do a car
accident
it actually was not my fault well that's
good because courtesy of today's sponsor
root insurance i could tell you about
how you could save up to 900
a year by getting rates based primarily
on how you drive
so i'm here in new york city to tell you
guys about the way that rude and true
down there buddy god this is a perfect
example people are driving crazy around
here they should have really bad rates
because they're a risk to other people
on the road but guess what
if you're not you could get a much
better rate through route insurance
it's actually pretty simple what they do
is they take the information based on
how you drive just like a regular maps
application does
and they use that to say hey timmy over
here and monica over there they're
driving great
tim and monica shouldn't be penalized
just for being
young right so root bases their rate
primarily on how
they drive so for all you safe drivers
out there consider checking out the link
in the description below because with
root you can start your test drive today
and you could save up to 900 a year just
just by driving around
i mean you're already doing it anyways
huge thanks to them for sponsoring this
episode and
hey i hope you guys save some money man
that was fun
clint it's good to have you back on the
couch we should come by again sometime
soon i absolutely will i want to come
back for a stuntman
react episode because i got some good
stunts sweet did you see me jump off the
roof
oh yeah i saw you jump off the roof that
was amazing i was so jealous i was like
so freaking cool thanks for giving me
the call and and uh
yeah coming back on the couch i'm glad
you could join us it's great to have you
back go check out clint's channel if you
miss him and want to see more of his
stuff youtube.com punisher now you guys
ready to play some smash bros
of course yes all right thanks for
watching everyone we'll see you next
week